hi there steve kaufman here um people
often ask me you know how do you find
the time to study languages
uh
certainly while i was working i was uh
you know very much involved in my lumber
business
um i work out i play old-timers hockey i
do all kinds of other stuff how do i
find the time to
learn languages
so
two bits of advice
first of all
figure out those tasks that you can
combine with language learning and that
means primarily listening so in my own
case i can drive and listen i can wait
in a doctor's office and listen or link
on my iphone
i can exercise i can do the dishes i can
clean the garage i can walk the dog so
there's a number of things that i'm
quite capable of doing while listening
to
language and i am able to focus much of
the time the second thing is
when you are focused on language
learning for example when i'm reading
about polish history and saving words to
my database and looking up again the
yellow saved links
we're learning words
very important
to be convinced that this is what you
want to do this is your
bliss for the moment this is where you
want to be this is your
sense of flow because it's too easy
nowadays to be distracted
you know look up your email go on
twitter uh wish you were watching a
hockey game on tv
in other words you have to and i think
this is true not only for language
learning but for any task today
really say wow this is what i want to do
i'm enjoying it i know that it's going
to help me i'm learning about polish
history i'm learning polish words just
running that polish through my system is
improving
my sense of the language i'm acquiring
words this is where i want to be so
those are the two quick tips here number
one find out those things that you can
combine with language learning and
second of all when you are focusing on
language learning
make sure that you convince yourself
that this is where you want to be
and see if i can make this work